hello friends john perry here
the other day i was on the internet and
as one does i was browsing the wildlife
and nature photography on stevecreek.com
he has really great pictures on there
but then i came across this photograph
what on earth
is going on here what does this thing
have in its mouth
many bird species produce a structure
like this today we're going to learn
exactly what this structure is and how
it is that birds evolved the ability to
produce
these bizarre
somewhat disturbing
structures
to figure out what this structure is
we're going to look at this wonderful
comic by the brilliant rosemary moscow
hopefully all of you are already
following rosemary on twitter which is
at rosemary moscow she does these
amazing cartoons about wildlife about
biology in general about evolution
really good stuff and actually
this particular comic requires two
people to read because there's like a
narration piece and then there's the the
voice of the robin maybe it would be
cool to get this robin to speak with a
french canadian accent i'll see if i can
i'll see if i can bug my wife hold on
maybe she'll come read for us okay she
agreed here we are
springtime advice from a robin
bask in the warm sun whenever you can
beautiful
find a partner who fills the air with
song
lovely words
build a strong coziness that is suitable
for three to five offspring sweet if
specific
consume fecal sex after each feeding but
begin to transport fecal sucks far away
from nest as the sun okay i think we're
done here
that's right my friends you heard
correctly this bird is eating a dookie a
dookie that has been entombed in a thick
durable rubbery sack produced by the
baby's body
actually in this case he's probably not
eating it because it's pretty big they
only eat them when they're really small
because when babies are really really
small baby birds they don't digest their
food very well and so it's actually
really highly nutritious and so the
mothers and the mother and the father
will actually munch on it when they're
low on calories now some of you might be
grossed out right now
but you shouldn't be
look at how amazing this is look at how
convenient this is
birds
come with their own automatic diapers
here's another person you should be
following on twitter if you're not
already sarah winiki she's holding one
of these fecal sacks in her hand and
they are they're really solid structures
it's not rubber it's mucus it's snot
it's intestinal snot
but it's a really thick fairly dry to
the touch
sort of a rubbery like substance how
cool would it be if human babies did
this we would never have had to invent
diapers
this brings us to evolutionary question
number 29
how did fecal sax
evolve
at first glance this seems like it's
just a luxury item right
baby produces its own diaper that's
pretty cool it's a luxury item and
luxury items don't really evolve very
often right in order for something to
evolve you need serious selection
pressures
well it turns out that there are serious
selection pressures involved
in the evolution of these sacs here
we're looking at a robin feeding her
babies robins have as we learned between
two to five babies at a time and these
things hatch blind and naked they're
very very premature when they hatch they
need very careful care the parents have
to constantly feed them constantly clean
up after them and so these fecal sex
they really are a matter of life and
death for many species of bird
unfortunately i do not have footage of a
robin dealing with a fecal sac but i do
have footage of the rufus collared
sparrow check this out i don't know if
this is a male or a female right here
because they look the same but
it feeds the baby and then
it goes and it grabs a fecal sac and
removes it from the nest it happens
really quick here's another footage this
is actually different footage
of the same nest
you can see it a little bit more clearly
here at the end
right there
bam that
that's so cool it turns out that i am
not the only person wondering how fecal
sex evolved scientists have also been
wondering this and they have been
studying this
there's a paper about it evolution of
nesting feces removal and avian
phylogeny what they found is that fecal
sex seemed to have evolved during an
evolutionary arms race against birds and
microbes so bacteria and viruses as
shown here and this that's actually
viruses coming out of bacteria it's a
really cool picture that i found on the
wikipedia thank you but what these
researchers found is that not all birds
have fecal sex and the reason that not
all birds have fecal sex is because a
lot of species of birds genuinely don't
need them many species of birds when
their babies hatch they're pretty much
good to go they're strong enough to exit
the nest they can poop outside the nest
if they need to some of them can even
hunt their own food already right as
soon as they hatch
most of them get a little bit of
parental care at least but a lot of them
are they're more efficient
self-sufficient than you would imagine
right out of the egg but in order for a
mother to build an egg inside of her
body that is large enough to produce a
baby that's ready to go as soon as it
hatches
that requires a lot of work the mother
has to build a huge egg yolk a huge egg
and while she's building that she's
extra heavy birds need to fly a lot of
them do building yolk is not easy yolk
is the food so you can you can either
build a huge yolk or you can feed your
babies
those are your two options right birds
that hatch strong kind of ready to go
out of the gate things like chickens and
ducks and so on i mean they're not
totally ready to go right out of the
gate it takes a couple hours before a
chicken will stand up and start walking
around but
it's only a couple of hours versus a
couple of weeks sometimes for some other
species a chicken's eyes are open pretty
much immediately
we call these species precocial species
and then other species of birds are what
we call altricial altrucial means that
they're born extremely prematurely they
hatch extremely prematurely they're
naked they're blind
they need help from their parents there
are pros and cons to this the the big
pro is that you can have tiny little
eggs look this is a chicken egg compared
to a pair of ultrasoul eggs the chicken
egg is huge
now i am cheating a little bit here in
this image because the atresial eggs
will actually belong to a hummingbird
but
still ultricia legs can be really really
small and that takes a huge burden off
the mother when she's producing those
eggs this photograph some people think
it's fake that i like photoshopped it
because the chicken egg is blue but
actually some species of chicken just
lay blue eggs i was in ecuador
and i was hanging out with some friends
and they gave me some eggs from their
chicken and then as i was walking away
from their house i just happened upon
this
hummingbird nest it was actually about
waist high and so i just bent down and
snapped this photo total serendipity i'm
really glad that i finally have a
legitimate reason to use this ecuador is
amazing by the way you should come with
me i'll talk more about that at the end
of the of the show here
so atracial eggs are much easier on the
mother when she's making those eggs but
it means that she's gonna have a lot of
poop to clean up later thus the
evolution of the mucus around bird feces
in species that hatch prematurely if we
want to understand the evolution of the
structure we first need to take a quick
look at the evolution of mucus in
general snot is far more important than
you may have imagined mucus evolved a
very very long time ago in fact all
animal species almost all animal species
sea sponges don't produce mucus but
almost everything else does
including
things like jellyfish and corals they
produce mucus
mucus evolved a very very long time ago
and it is incredibly useful here's
another comic from rosemary moscow
burdenmoon.com these are just several of
the ways that different animals have
evolved to use mucus you've got the
queen parrotfish which actually makes a
a net of mucus around itself before it
goes to sleep and that protects it from
predators the hagfish hag fish are
really really cool because if if they
get bit by a shark or something they
will immediately produce mucus at an
incredible incredible rate so much that
it will actually choke the fish that bit
them and i've heard that it can actually
get caught in their gills and kill them
in rare cases but normally it just it
fills their mouth and
weirds them out and they they swim away
and then you've got the uh the violet
sea snail which actually blows bubbles
in its own snot then uses those bubbles
to float on the top of the ocean
it's so cool it's useful for everything
but its main function its original
function probably
is to defend against viruses and
bacteria here we've got a drawing a
microbial drawing by david goodsell he
does these really cool anatomically
accurate cartoons of microbes and the
green
noodley structures here are mucons
glycoproteins so it's a protein covered
with sugar don't eat your boogers if
you're on a low carb diet all right
don't don't do it it's protein and sugar
these things act as a major first line
defense against viruses humans have over
20 different types of mucon genes so
genes that produce mucous molecules
some of them are trans membrane mucons
and so you got kind of like a snot layer
that hangs out on the outside of a cell
so look at look at the tail down here it
goes down into the cell membrane and so
that that anchors it to the cell
others are just drifting in fluid
they're in solution and here's what they
look like under a microscope they have
this beautiful feathery structure to
them and they're slippery
and this long feathery structure allows
them to stick to each other and kind of
tangle with each other and that's what
makes mucus such a neat and useful
structure you got a you know mucus
inside your lungs
it forms a very very thin barrier and
it's a barrier that if it rips open it
will self-heal in a way you could say
just because these things that they
re-tangle together it's a self-healing
material and it protects your lungs
against diseases i mean not perfectly
obviously but pretty darn well mucus is
also lining your intestines and it coats
the outside of your feces just like it
coats the outside of those little baby
birds feces but of course in humans the
mucous layer is extremely extremely thin
within humans there's a ver there's
variation as to how much mucus there is
in your intestines so there is variation
on the thickness of the layer
of mucus surrounding your feces
and the same is true amongst pretty much
all animals including birds and this
gives us a clue as to how these fecal
sex may have evolved darwin was really
big into gradualism he actually loosened
up on his strict gradualism later on in
his life but when he first wrote his
book on evolution this is what he said
if it could be demonstrated that any
complex organ existed which could not
possibly have been formed by numerous
successive slight modifications my
theory would absolutely break down now
even though it is true that from person
to person there is a difference in the
thickness of mucus in the intestines and
that gives us a start a good start as to
how this may have evolved but there's a
pretty big difference between having a
thin layer of mucus
versus having a solid durable sack and
it actually does make it kind of tricky
to think about how this could have
evolved in a step-by-step manner there
are several ways it could have happened
it might be a classic example of
exception an exception is where a trait
evolved for one
reason one problem one selection
pressure and was then co-opted
for a second function
it's not hard to imagine that there was
some bird species somewhere it was
really struggling the only things good
for it to eat in its environment were
berries that were
toxic and
only the babies with extra mucus in
their intestines were able to survive
eating this toxic berry that the the
parents were feeding to it and then you
can imagine here you've got a nice a
nice place for a gradual increase in
mucus because those with stronger mucus
are more immune to this toxin until
eventually you get full on sac
production and once you have sac
production well now you have a whole
nother trait this new trait is useful
not just for preventing poisoning from
this toxin it's also really handy when
mom and dad are trying to clean up after
your mess so that's one route that this
could have taken
but actually it turns out that
in the case of mucus
darwin might have been being too hard on
himself here this is one of these rare
cases one of these rare adaptations that
actually could have evolved in a single
step and the reason that i say that is
that we know
mucon genes are highly highly
evolvable so the past few videos i've
been talking a lot about this little
piece of computer tape here this is
computer tape from an old russian
computer data used to be stored on
pieces of paper like this that computers
would read and that data was stored as
holes punched in this tape
and the reason i've been talking about
this so much lately is because dna is
sort of like this here we have a
physical information storage structure
and
the information that we store
changes
the physical properties of the storage
device the parts of data that require
lots of holes for that data to be
encoded
those parts make
this strip of data weaker if i were to
pull on it it's going to break in the
weakest point and the weakest point is
going to be produced by the data that is
embedded in this piece of paper should i
do it should i do it should i pull on it
and see where it breaks should we see
which piece of data is the most
vulnerable to damage
i'll tell you what i don't want to do
that because this is this is one of my
coolest uh little teaching tools but if
this video gets
100 000 views
i'll do it i'll make a video where i
break
on purpose
i break
my favorite
little teaching device okay the reason i
bring that up is because dna is also
like this certain sequences of
nucleotides encoded information certain
sequences are weaker they are physically
weaker and they cause mutations to
happen at unusually high rates and these
mucon genes especially muc2 and muc6 in
the human genome again we have over 20
different mucon genes but muc2 and muc6
they are highly highly vulnerable to
mutation they hyper mutate they have
highly repetitive nucleotide units in
their sequence and in dna repetitive
units are super super fragile some
scientists speculate that this is not a
fluke this is an example of evolved
evolvability because mucus is so
important for fighting against pathogens
protecting us against viruses and
bacteria it's actually really useful if
siblings have dramatically different
mucus and the reason that's useful is
that if one of them gets sick and this
virus or this bacteria is able to adapt
to that that individual's mucus it won't
necessarily be adapted to the sibling's
mucus
that prevents a mother from losing all
of her children in a pandemic therefore
hypermutability in mucon genes could be
selected for by natural selection darwin
may have been too hard on himself here
granted a fecal sac isn't really an
organ and it's certainly not a complex
organ but it is difficult to imagine the
value of half a fecal sac unless of
course you think it evolved through
exception but in this case i think you
could actually get here with a single
mutation because mutations are so common
in mucon genes and they can actually be
really big mutations large insertions
and large deletions
at least a clumsy first version of it
could have evolved in a single mutation
this could have evolved immediately
once this evolved whether it happened
gradually or immediately once it evolved
it allowed babies who were born or
hatched prematurely it allowed them to
survive mothers that have to deal with
these premature babies well at least
they don't have to deal with all the
nasty feces it's packaged up nicely for
them they can clean up after these
babies they can do this
once this adaptation evolved the
extremely useful adaptation of altracial
eggs
could also evolve birds could expand
into much greater niches they could
conquer all sorts of new environments
that were previously unconquerable to me
this is just such a neat
series of discoveries that people have
made like
one thing evolved and led to the
evolution of the other
and now we have birds
in our backyards that are born
prematurely
and have fecal sacs
so there you have it
the snot and turds
of evolution
make sure to check out rosemary moscow's
stuff if you haven't already
don't forget to uh you know like and
share and comment so we can get this up
to 100 000 views and before i go i want
to talk again about ecuador today is
april 28th i've talked about the ecuador
tour before in just a couple of days the
early bird special
on this year's ecuador tour is going to
be closing so if you want to join me in
ecuador we're going to go to the amazon
we're going to see river dolphins stuff
you've never seen before in your life
it's going to be awesome if you want to
join me this year for a new year's
celebration in the amazon jungle and
we're going to learn a lot about
evolution make sure you sign up now we
only have two spots left
there is a link to the sign up website
down in the video description
so long for now my friends
stay curious
you